paukenschlag für die häusliche pflege
ausländischen pflegekräften steht laut
bundesarbeitsgericht mindestlohn zu auch
für bereitschaftszeiten
ein hauch von abschied angela merkel
verkündet im bundestag ihre wohl letzte
regierungserklärung und winterlandschaft
die niemand braucht in süddeutschland
richten unwetter mit teils
golfballgroßen frage erheblichen schäden
an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halben abend schön dass sie
dabei sind wir auch norbert lehmann für
den sportverein schon am tag vor mir
mehr pflegebedürftige eltern hat für den
sind sie oft die rettung meist frauen
aus osteuropa die bei den senioren zu
hause wohnen sie rundum betreuen und das
für relativ wenig geld
jetzt hat das bundesarbeitsgericht in
erfurt klar gestellt auch sie müssen
mindestlohn bekommen und zwar auch für
bereitschaftszeiten dadurch dürfte
pflege deutlich teurer werden birgit
franke betreuungskraft du blinder ist
wieder in ihrer heimat bulgarien 2015
hat sie sieben monate lang eine
pflegebedürftige senioren in berlin
betreut bezahlt wurde sie laut
arbeitsvertrag für sechs stunden täglich
realistisch sein ist 24 stunden gewesen
sie haben von mir erwartet dass ich
koche einkaufen putzen waschen bügeln
sie überall hin begleitet ich war immer
auf abruf zimmer in der wohnung oder bei
der patientin
ich habe da auch gegessen und geschlafen
sabrina fakt lang ihre bulgarische
arbeitgeberin fordert für die rund um
die uhr betreuung knapp 43.000 euro
abzüglich der schon geleisteten
vergütungen das bundesarbeitsgericht
schlechter heute zunächst klar
ausländische pflegekräfte die nach
deutschland entsandt werden haben
anspruch auf den gesetzlichen
mindestlohn und das bezieht sich auf
alle geleisteten arbeitsstunden dass es
dann nicht nur so genannte voll arbeit
sondern auch sogenannte
bereitschaftszeiten der anwalt der
beklagten arbeitgeberin zieht jetzt viel
arbeit auf die pflegebranche zu kommen
die branche wird natürlich jetzt
versuchen müssen wie gesagt nicht zum
nachteil der pflegekräfte ihr ganzes
vertragswerk zu neu zu gestalten es geht
um geschätzte 100.000 ausländische
betreuungskräfte die zukünftig mehr geld
für ihre arbeit verlangen können für
viele alte pflegebedürftige in
deutschland bedeutet ist aber eine
katastrophe
das ist richtig aber hat natürlich
fatale folgen für die menschen die zu
hause gepflegt werden denn das ist ein
erdbeben was eine kosten tsunami
auslösen wird und das können die
menschen zu hause gar nicht tragen in
welchem umfang briner vollarbeit oder
bereitschaft geleistet hat das muss
jetzt noch einmal das
landesarbeitsgericht berlin brandenburg
entscheiden
felix zimmermann ist bei mir unser
rechtsexperte felix eine ganz
entscheidende frage ist ja welche
stunden bereitschaft an einem tag zu
bezahlen wenn das bundesarbeitsgericht
hat erstmal klar gemacht also ausbeutung
darf nicht sein für personen die bei auf
bereitschaft parat stehen ob ein
ausländer oder inländer man ja und was
ist bereitschaft eigentlich jede zeit
die nicht frei zur verfügung stellt auch
wenn man eben als arbeitnehmerin zum
beispiel eben die tür offen lassen muss
jemand schlägt wenn man die betreute
person der eben ständig da sein muss die
ständig zur verfügung stehende da ist
eben wirklich so dass der mindestlohn
gilt und das ist natürlich ein problem
für die zu pflegenden person und es wird
natürlich unglaublich teuer wenn man
sich vorstellten personen braucht
wirklich 24 stunden rund um betreuung
ist man schnell bei 7 oder 10.000 euro
naja tricksereien helfen da nichts man
kann nicht wie in dem fall sagen naja am
arbeitsvertrag der stehen auch nur 30
stunden
wenn die gesamtumstände so sind dass die
person wirklich ständig da sein muss und
ständig zur verfügung stehen muss muss
eben auch der mindestlohn gezahlt werden
es ist ein wegweisendes urteil aber
trotzdem wird sich für viele frauen die
in diesen jobs aber den diesen jobs
arbeiten nichts ändern oder ja in der
tat denn die sehr viele verdi schätzt
über mehrere hunderttausend personen
sind illegal in deutschland
und dieses urteil dürfte diese situation
der illegalen beschäftigung natürlich
noch mal verstärken
denn viele familien sind jetzt eben vor
der herausforderung und gott das können
wir nicht bezahlen mit legalen mitteln
was tun wir natürlich ist da die
schwarzarbeit keine lösung das ist
strafbar zum beispiel
sozialversicherungsbetrug aber eben eine
sehr schwierige situation die dazu
führen könnte dass noch mehr prekäre
verhältnisse arbeitsverhältnisse
entstehen die natürlich eigentlich
dieses urteil auch verhindern wird
deswegen ist die politik jetzt umso
der aufgerufene neue modelle zu
entwickeln die einerseits wirklich
beschäftigung sozialverträglich möglich
ist und andererseits eben pflege möglich
ist unterstützung zum beispiel auch
durch personen angehörige das alles zu
verbessern
finanzielle möglichkeiten zu schaffen
eine echte herausforderung fehlen dann
felix zimmermann ein tag des abschieds
war es heute im parlament angela merkel
hielt ihre wohl letzte rede im bundestag
nach 31 jahren als abgeordnete davon
knapp 16 als kanzlerin
sie selbst blieb streng inhaltlich
vorwiegend bei ihrem kernthema europa
alle anderen ausser der afg sollten ihr
respekt und der potenziellen nachwuchs
lief sich schon mal warm aus berlin
weniger sie kann den kampf um ihre
nachfolge heute live miterleben
armin laschet hatte sich überraschend
auf die rednerliste setzen lassen
im wahlkampf zählt jeder auftritt auch
annalena baerbock und olaf scholz werden
reden er ist aber die kanzlerin
geschäftsmäßig wie immer corona im
patente europa ich bin überzeugt dass
wir nur zusammen als staatengemeinschaft
erfolgreich die hause herausforderung
der pandemie wie auch der anderen großen
aufgaben meistern können eine souverän
der europäische union sollte hier ein
starker partner sein und daran werden
wir heute und morgen auch in brüssel
herzlichen dank das war wahrscheinlich
merkels letzte regierungserklärung sie
nimmt nach außen ungerührt wie immer dem
folgt auch wie immer afd fundamental
opposition auch diese
regierungserklärung ist vorbei gegangen
wie alle anderen ohne einen funken
einsicht in die fehlentscheidung die
ihren weg als kanzlerin zäumen berbalk
wird sich bei merkel bedanken genauso
wie der vizekanzler
laschet ändert bis zur letzten minute er
rechnet mit der afg ab
die deutschland aus der europäischen
union herausführen will
sie schaden deutschen interessen das ist
das was ihrer politik behörden und was
sie anstellen mit ihrem gebäude
ich möchte mich bei der bundeskanzlerin
für die zusammenarbeit in der
europapolitik in den letzten vier jahren
bedanken
wir haben viele fortschritte für europa
erreicht das ist nicht
selbstverständlich gewesen dass sie in
krisensituationen in den letzten 16
jahren dieses europa zusammengehalten
haben gerade auch gegen große
widerstände aus ihrer eigenen fraktion
und vor allen dingen von ihrer
schwesterpartei auch andere amtszeiten
enden
horst seehofers oder die von martin
schulz während der noch mit der träne im
knopfloch kämpft hat angela merkel ihre
handtasche schon geschnappt sie geht
vorzeitig wie immer nur eben zum letzten
mal vom bundestag ging es für die
kanzlerin weiter nach brüssel zum eu
gipfel
da steht viel high class auf dem
programm heute bekam vor allem ungarns
ministerpräsident orban die geballte
empörung zu spüren über sein
umstrittenes gesetz zur sexuellen
minderheiten mehr als die hälfte der
mitgliedstaaten hält es für
diskriminierend und verlangt
gegenmaßnahmen connor krüger berichtet
27 fahnen auf dem weg zum gipfel doch
das thema dass fast alle ansprechen
wollen hat andere farbe
das ist eine schamlose diskriminierung
ungarische regierung verletzt die
grundwerte der europäischen union
der so gescholtene tritt lässig auf
europas laufsteg ein gesetz dass
homosexuelle diskriminieren soll sontra
wird man so ein gesetz haben wir nicht
wir haben 1 das die rechte von kindern
und eltern schützt will er heute darüber
reden dass ich nicht auf der agenda
russland steht dagegen auf der agenda
nicht nur weil er vor einem richter
steht der fall weil sie zeigt erneut die
eu braucht eine russland strategie
frankreich und deutschland haben dafür
einen vorschlag die antworten wir
geschlossen auf die provokation und wie
können wir vielleicht auch
gesprächsformat herstellenden konflikte
kann man am besten lösen
das sollte man am amerikanischen
präsidenten gesehen wenn man auch
miteinander spricht neben
wirtschaftssanktionen wäre also auch ein
treffen möglich so wie es beiden und
putin hatten doch osteuropäer und balken
halten die nach hamburg für mich dem
foto
ich glaube nicht dass es jetzt schon
zeit ist für so einen gipfel auf
chefebene was hat sich denn bislang
kinder erst brauche es frieden in der
ukraine
und so führt ein vorschlag der einigkeit
zum ziel hat erst mal zu streit
in hongkong ist die letzte laute
pressestimme für die demokratie
verstummt die zeitung apple daily gibt
auf schon am frühen morgen war die
letzte ausgabe vergriffen
am ende war der druck aus china zu groß
zuletzt wurden führende mitarbeiter
festgenommen und konten eingefroren
wegen angeblicher verstöße gegen das
sogenannte sicherheitsgesetz
us-außenminister blinken ist in berlin
heute besuchte er mit außenminister maß
das holocaust denkmal
sie unterzeichneten eine vereinbarung
die erinnerungskultur auch in zukunft
wachzuhalten linken erklärte dies werde
helfen uns an all das zu erinnern was
wir verlieren können
er stammt selbst aus einer jüdischen
familie kommen wir zur corona lage in
deutschland die entspannt sich weiter
das robert koch institut meldet 1008
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 322 weniger als letzten donnerstag
93 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages hinzu die sieben tage incident
sinkt auf 6,6 damit weiterhin möglichst
viele menschen geimpft werden können
gibt es die impfzentren doch dort
erscheinen viele gar nicht mehr zu ihren
terminen mecklenburg vorpommern
verzeichnet einen täglichen ausfall von
bis zu 40 prozent in rheinland-pfalz
sackten zuletzt 15 prozent der
angemeldeten nicht einmal ab ähnlich die
situation in sachsen über die
beweggründe der menschen dort cornelia
schiemenz der ganz große ansturm auf
sachsens hausarztpraxen und impfzentren
ist vorbei viele haben längst einen
impftermin bekomme nun gilt es die zu
erreichen die noch zögern die sächsische
sozialministerin spricht gar von
beginnen der impfmüdigkeit der sommer
ist da weniger instanzen manchmal sehr
fast 1 1 oder 2 und da sagen die leute
ist doch vorbei und
da war nicht eben so ein stück weiter
vor dass ich eben glaube dass wir
durchaus wieder steigende instanz im
herbst haben werden und wir möchten
gerne einen guten herbst und nicht noch
einen guten sommer verleben besonders
junge menschen zögern zahlen das recht
ein bisschen gegen ruhige und dass man
vielleicht ohne impfung rumkommt in den
impfzentren kann sich inzwischen jeder
impfen lassen angebot und nachfrage
halten sich in sachsen die waage doch
man ist besorgt denn 15 prozent der
zweit impfungen werden hier nicht
wahrgenommen
zum teil weil menschen einfach zum
hausarzt gewechselt sind aber das dak
hat stichprobenartig auch nach anderen
gründen gefragt
tatsächlich frappierend gewesen es viele
auch gesagt hab ach ja es war so ein
schönes wird derartig waren garten ich
hab's vergessen und das rüttelt uns
schon auf und rüttelt uns wach zu sagen
okay wir müssen hier gegen schlimmste es
gibt ganz klare daten und hinweise
darauf dass wenn ich die erste impfung
habe zwar einen gewissen schutz habe
aber das ist nur ein teil schutz und er
reicht nicht aus um mich wirklich voll
umfänglich zu schützen
sachsen wird nun kräftig die impf
werbetrommel 80% impfquote so das ziel
wer in den nächsten wochen mit der bahn
fährt muss erst mal nicht mit streiks
rechnen die lokführergewerkschaft gdl
hat erklärt sie werde am 9 august
bekanntgeben ob eine mehrheit ihrer
mitglieder für einen arbeitskampf ist
erst danach würden entscheidungen
getroffen
die deutsche bahn kritisierte die
angekündigte urabstimmung und fordert
die gdl auf an den verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren
deutschland muss beim klimaschutz
nachlegen das hat das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ende april
klar gemacht als reaktion darauf
entscheidet der bundestag in diesen
minuten über das neue klimaschutzgesetz
das ziel klimaneutralität im jahr 2045
heißt dann darf man noch so viel co2
ausgestoßen werden wie zum beispiel
durch bäume absorbiert werden kann ihren
kehl htg nur noch ein paar tage dann
wird der ältere block des
kohlekraftwerks duisburg abgeschaltet
der ausstieg aus der kohle läuft die
energieerzeuger müssen mitziehen denn
sie dürfen in den nächsten jahren nur
noch bestimmte mengen an treibhausgasen
freisetzen das neue klima gesetz
verschärft jetzt noch einmal die
sparvorgaben bis 2030 besonders im
energiesektor um weitere 38 prozent die
industrie muss zusätzliche 16 prozent
reduzieren andere bereich etwas weniger
klare vorgaben auf dem papier wie das in
der praxis umgesetzt werden soll ist
dann aufgabe der nächsten regierung
ich denke die knüpfung an die sektoren
ist ein guter und ein richtiger ansatz
nur die konkreten maßnahmen fehlen noch
das wird eine harte aufgabe sein für die
neuen fach ministerinnen und minister
das hinzubekommen auch im gesetz neue
ausschreibungen für windkraftanlagen im
nächsten jahr plus 25 prozent auf gut 4
gigawatt und auch für sonnenstrom plus
200 prozent auf 6 gigawatt an der
deutliche steigerung aber nur ein anfang
insgesamt wird das so nicht ausreichend
wenn allein der bedarf an wasserstoff an
so genannten grünen wasserstoff der über
erneuerbare energien hergestellt wird
das verbraucht so viel erneuerbare
energien wie wir im moment im netz haben
da wird die größenordnung deutlich es
wird auf keinen fall ausreichen
aus dem gesetz gestrichen die solardach
pflicht für neubauten vielleicht noch
eine aufgabe für die nächste regierung
das neue gesetz im wahlkampf ja wohl nur
eine etappe in sachen klimaschutz
gewitter begleiten uns derzeit nahezu
täglich es stürmt schüttet und mancher
orts hagelt es heftig besonders
betroffen sind der süden und südwesten
seit gestern gibt es dort keine
wirkliche entspannen anton ja nie mit
einem überblick
bilder wie im winter in bempflingen im
kreis esslingen kommen gegen hagel
massen schwere maschinen zum einsatz
15 minuten hat hier das unwetter gewütet
die gewitterfront zieht am
spätnachmittag über baden württemberg
und bayern und sorgt für schwere schäden
also was uns heute hier getroffen hat
haben wir alles so noch nicht erlebt
werden also hagel der
gefühl dass einrichtungen kamen wir
hatten starke niederschläge
letztendlich kann man sich so vorstellen
dass die einlaufschächte durch den hd
verstopft waren dass das wasser sich auf
den straßen geschaut hat und dann seinen
weg gesucht hat
auch hier in metzingen am rand der
schwäbischen alb heißt ist land unter
hagelkörner manche tennisballgroße
prasseln vom himmel durchschlagen dächer
beschädigen autos durch die altstadt von
tübingen fließt wie diese
amateuraufnahmen zeigen sogar einfluss
aus hage können die feuerwehren können
kaum alle hilferufe erfüllen so viele
von uns sind selber betroffen mit
schäden zu hause mussten auch dort
erstmal nach der familie gucken und
vielleicht nach den eigenen vier wänden
gucken dass da nichts schlimmeres
passiert ist
nach ersten schätzungen gehen die
schäden in die millionen
in der landwirtschaft drohen
ernteverluste und aktuell wütend im
südwesten schon neue gewitter mit
starkregen und hagel und beim putzen wir
verbringen abend nerven aufreibend rage
das ganze wohl laut sagen aber
hauptsache das dfb team ist weiter
allerdings mit ganz ganz viel dusel
eigentlich stimmte ja gar nichts im
deutschen spiel gestern abend beim 2 2
gegen ungarn
bis auf eines die moral sozusagen mit
kampf und krampf ins achtelfinale
geschafft am dienstag geht's gegen
england es fehlte nicht viel und es wäre
sein letzter einsatz als bundestrainer
gewesen
kurz vor schluss erzielte leon goretzka
doch noch den erlösenden ausgleich ein
happy end nach einem denkwürdigen duell
wir haben fehler gemacht im spiel aber
die moral war sagenhaft man hatte immer
das gefühl wir bleiben dran und wir
kommen zurück und wir sind in der lage
den ausgleich zu erzielen in der gruppe
war es jetzt das allerwichtigste
durchzukommen auch nach drei spielen
immer noch in der findungsphase
die einstellung stimmte doch spielerisch
lief wenig zusammen
bei beiden gegentoren ein wildes
durcheinander die defensive nicht titel
tauglich eine dürftige vorstellung die
wenig mut macht für den kracher gegen
ändert die erste nachricht was wir
gehört haben nach dem spiel wir sind
durch und lag gegen ihr spiel gegen
england in wembley
das ist das schlimmste was man sich
vorstellen ich freue mich gigantisch
drauf spielen dann auch noch in england
gegen england in summe in so einem
geilen stadion ich glaube viel mehr geht
nicht
löw braucht taktisch neue lösungen denn
noch einmal so eine leistung wie gestern
wird dienstag in wembley wohl nicht zum
weiterkommen reichen
klar muss also einiges besser werden im
deutschen spiel
welche veränderungen müssten dass sein
sven voss in herzogenaurach
der bundestrainer hat jetzt die
gesammelten erkenntnisse aus drei
vorrundenspielen und muss nun eine idee
fürs achtelfinale gegen england
entwickeln vielleicht kommt er zu dem
schluss dass das modell viererkette mit
einem zentralen josua kimmig davor gegen
ungarn ganz gut funktioniert hat und
dank seiner torgefährlichkeit ist leon
goretzka vielleicht endlich ein mann für
die startelf bei thomas müller hilft
natürlich jeder tag bis dienstag um fit
zu werden für die anfangsformation
insgesamt hält der bundestrainer also
viele schlüssel in der hand jetzt muss
er den richtigen finden um die bislang
gute englische abwehr zu knacken und das
tor zum viertelfinale aufzuschließen
das war sven voss gegen herzogenaurach
und das war's formiert von forschern
gerne der deutsche wetterdienst warnt
aktuell wieder vor schweren gewittern
und starkregen im südwesten mehr dazu
gleich vom ersten tag
christian sievers freut sich auf sie im
heute journal zu gewohnter zeit um
viertel vor zehn und wir freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder da
sind danke für ihr interesse und einen
schönen abend noch auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das hier ist unser
unwetter tief was heute schon für
heftige gewitter gesorgt hat mit hagel
sturm teilte orkanböen das wird auch in
der ersten nachthälfte so weitergehen
und es verlagert sich allmählich nach
osten und vor allem im südosten
deutschlands morgen dann wieder heftige
gewitter im unwetter bereich in der
nacht wird es also erst einmal weiter
gewittern im südosten teilweise heftig
mit hagel sturm und auch durchaus
orkanböen und sehr viele regen in kurzer
zeit in der zweiten nachthälfte lässt
das allmählich nach dann geht es im
dauerregen über im norden ist es
größtenteils trocken temperaturen sinken
im nordwesten auf 7 grad und 15 grad zum
beispiel im südosten morgen in der
nordhälfte überwiegend trockenes wetter
je weiter man nach süden schaut desto
mehr wolken sind dabei und die schon
gesagt im südosten teils unwetterartige
entwicklungen mit hagel und sturmböen
und viel regen temperaturen dazu 24 grad
im osten und 18 grad an den alpen und
die nächsten tage werden trockener und
sonniger und stabiler am samstag im ost
noch eine gewitter bis 26 grad und
montag bis 32 grad aber wie der neu
gewitter einen schönen abend